thank you
[Music]
this my friends of just kidding news
fannery
is a story of Revenge in three Acts
so when I was in high school I had a
best friend not a joke his name was also
Steve perhaps that was how he got on
initially in our first meeting with each
other hey your name's Steve
that's my name dude
cool
we were friends ever since not really a
joke well then
um we would go camping together in his
backyard or my backyard we would hang
quite a bit I would say that this was my
first encounter with a quote-unquote
best friend when you're of the age where
you share things with you with each
other that you would not want to tell
your parents about like I have hair on
my balls and stuff like that
so now
fast forward a little bit we're in high
school there's a girl that I have been
into ever since I met Steve and he knows
that and I know that well once we're in
high school
things start to pick up with this girl a
little bit and me
things get good
they get real good
[Music]
but just before
wow we really could make it official AKA
do anything in her car because I didn't
have a car I still don't
[Music]
[Laughter]
she she uh she started to get a little
bit weird with me
is kind of odd
she uh didn't want to hang out as much
she she starts
hanging out a little bit with Steve
I didn't really understand what was
going on
[Music]
so one day we all used to hang together
at lunch me Steve and this girl
one day um
Steve decides to to have a conversation
with me because Kristen tells me hey I
need to talk to Steve and I'm like okay
cool I'll talk to you at lunch Krista no
problem
well Kristen uh during lunch stays put
and I'm like hey Steve I think me and
Kristen need to have a conversation
right now
and Steve's like no I think you and me
didn't have a conversation that's what
Steve said no
so he broke the news to me that him and
Kristen we're going we're have been
seeing each other for now for a little
while a couple couple days
just wanted to let you know on the up
and up
foreign
[Music]
the ball of anger that immediately Rose
in my body
and I said
that's fine dude
and he's like really
we're good and I was like
we're good see
couldn't believe his life he got to be
with Kristen he got his best buds still
he basically picked up a basketball
threw it behind him and it went in
swish except
it didn't
so began
what I call the systematic destruction
[Laughter]
of my friend Steve
because from that point forward
we were no longer friends
he just didn't know that yet
[Music]
so I started to just be chill
I couldn't have been a more chill best
friend it was like I was hired for the
park
I would see them all at school I'd hang
out with them at lunch I was all smiles
I I would I would go get donuts I was
like who wants donuts and it's like oh
Steve's a cool donut guy well
one day
Kristen
brought her friend around
and I was like oh our friend's kind of
cool
maybe I'll start a relationship with her
and that's exactly what I did I was also
the lead in the school play again
but this time I was the lead in the
school play that Steve was the side
character in so he's like my best friend
in it right all right
so
Christian has to come to all the
rehearsals
she has to see me on the stage with
those bright lights
she's watching me kill it but most
importantly she's watching me kill it
while looking at Allison and being like
oh man you're cool
time goes by
doing the play the reviews are in it's a
hot show
high school's never seen the show this
good before that people don't know what
to do there's newspaper overlays during
this conversation that we're having
right now through like everyone's giving
it top score
so so Kristin
in the front row at every every single
show and I'm the last one to come out
she's always
that takes a toll on a woman
just before the end of the first run of
our shows we're doing it for two weeks
I'll never forget
Kristen calls me
and she's like
hey um
you know I've been thinking about like
you me
I'm like
and she's like oh yeah I've been I've
been thinking about like you know what
we maybe had together
and I'm like oh well that's interesting
I mean uh do you want to come over and
talk about it
[Music]
started
went through a little bit you know we
were all just friends I can't wait why
can't I hang with her
so then Steve's like whoa well wait I'm
not really like why aren't you guys
hanging with me and I'm like oh no we're
just me hanging with Kristen like we're
totally chill like you want a donut
[Laughter]
So
eventually Kristen and I are hanging
quite a bit but we're also hanging while
Steve's there
and when Steve would go to the bathroom
Kristen would sometimes jump in my lap
and start making out with me
so good everything's coming up Steve
Green again
Life's good I'm feeling great I'm
leaving my house I'm going to school I
got this chick who really digs me oh
yeah I forgot about Allison but that's
because I was already kind of like
oopsie daisies with that anyways
basically I had I had to dump Allison do
the right thing even though I got with
her for horrible reasons
foreign thing at the end so I dump her
and then you know there was like this
assessed period where maybe me and her
were making out some and then also also
was making out with Kristen some
but like I was trying to do the right
thing I mean
so
part of my family
my parents were like second parents to
him my brothers were like brothers to
him
well once Steve kind of caught wind that
Kristen no longer wanted to be with him
and she wanted to be with me
[Music]
Steve started to realize that people in
my home weren't going to be as available
to him as maybe he thought before he
betrayed me
so I'll never forget Steve calls my
house
and he's like
hey um is your brother there and I'm
like
yes he is who would like to speak with
him he's like Steve and I'm like oh yeah
no you you're not gonna get to speak
with him he's like why not I'm like
because he's my brother and so were you
until you did what you did you son of a
[ __ ]
and I said how does it feel now that the
shoe is on the other foot
never ever ever call my house again
and I hung up the phone and that was it
and then he started hanging out at high
schools after we all graduated for like
way too long and like it was kind of
weird
[Applause]
[Music]
wow amazing thank you
what a crazy ass story dude
so much more but I wanted to play it to
the music a little bit but yeah wait
what this is a donut guy that was
amazing what other stuff happened that
you left out well actually
um so he had told me it sucks I blew the
landing on the on the shooting of the
foot thing because he told me how would
you feel if the shoe was on the other
foot about like so when he first
um he's like Kristen likes me man and
how would you feel if the shoes on the
other foot right so when he was he when
he pulled me aside he said you know
Kristen likes me how you know how would
you feel the shoes on your foot and I
was like yeah okay I get it dude like
walking away of course [ __ ] you bro but
locking it away for sure but then like I
got to use that at the end of our
friendship I got to use that same line
because that's how dang that would have
been hard dude but you know what hey
it's still 8.6 out of 10 for sure
[Music]
nice the true tail uh saddest thing is
honestly Allison's so cool and like
she's just into some bystander really
and I did like her and stuff it's just
that like my revenge play I think just
grew and grew and grew in my body and
took over everything else
dude it sounded like it the funny thing
of you going you want to talk to my
brother you were once my brother
I can't talk to him he's my brother
dude it's that was real because he was
like he was honestly like family to all
of us and like when when me and him were
no longer friends anymore it was like
hard for my parents and everybody yeah
integrated into like the daily thing
yeah and his dad warned us his dad was
an awesome dude he was like hey don't
ever let a girl get between you guys
whatever he told us it's like we're in
Middle School like whatever dad doesn't
even happen that's gross yeah it's my
best friend yeah dude no actually I mean
you know like that was the that was I
didn't ever say like hey I called that
chick this was the one girl that he knew
about for like [ __ ] years that I was
so into it's like that's what made it
like so visceral for me and I was like
oh this will not like we are not friends
already too tempted huh oh and they
tested me once this is another thing I
left the store too because whatever but
they tested me once they actually fake
broke up
they test to see how I would react to it
wow that's [ __ ] weird I was eating
even cooler donut guy that day
dude the Revenge play is even sicker now
it's so funny
extra extra extra thick that day because
I something was [ __ ] weird about it
like Steve's like I was like like
they're both being quiet and I was like
what the [ __ ] going on and I was like
and then I was like hey dude are you are
you guys okay is everything okay he's
like oh yeah me and Kristen broke up and
I was like dude I am so sorry man that's
[ __ ] crazy like would you like glaze
you want powdered
jelly but like I was just being extra
extra cool and then he told me like like
the next day that they just they
couldn't believe how awesome a friend I
was and [ __ ] oh my God I was like bless
your [ __ ] hard yeah I gotta say I
gotta say my favorite part of the story
is when you're like yeah there might
have been like a little cessmo where I
was making out with Allison and Kristen
but I was trying to do this she just got
wrapped up on my play that's a little
bit that's great dude thanks guys
appreciate it thank you great story
great story
amazing
[ __ ] the news yeah
[ __ ] the news this is way better than
news how can we go back
[Music]
[Music]